have a peculiar insight
into the phenomena of agency captured
and that is the dynamic by which
environmental agencies and public health
agencies
become sock puppets of the industries
that are supposed to regulate it happens
with every agency so
everything it happens with all of them
whether it's the sec or the fda or you
know the uh hcc
yeah any of the three letter agencies
ultimately
over time the industry figures out how
to infiltrate them how to control the
senators and the congressmen that write
their budgets
how to get control of that agency
because it's so
important for their profit ambitions
right
and so
i probably brought over 500 lawsuits as
an environmental lawyer
mainly against polluters who are
discharging into the environment into
the air water whatever
but probably during the 38 years that i
was doing that probably 20 of my
lawsuits were against the epa or the
state environmental agencies for
issuing these kind of sweetheart illegal
permits because they get compromised
also you're saying as they get
compromised so i was used to that
dynamic right it's kind of hard to
navigate
of seeing the agency that's supposed to
be my friend but it's actually my enemy
you know on these
environmental issues
i was accustomed to that but
that dynamic is particularly acute it's
really on steroids
in public health agencies because there
are these unprecedented entanglements
financial entanglements for example
fda gets
45 of its annual budget from
pharmaceutical companies oh they're
really you know there's really no it's
kind of a seamless
subsidiary of the industry and it's
really
it's agency capture on steroids so the
fda is funded mostly by pharmaceutical
companies about half of their money
comes from pharmaceutical companies and
that's because
we passed a law in the
um
in the 90s
at a la actually in the in the early
2000s that allows it's called fast track
approval so the drug companies were
complaining that you know these drugs
take 10 years to get approved
and a lot of the particularly the
republicans on capitol hill who want the
agencies to be more industry friendly
they said there ought to be a process
where the where the industry can come in
and pay
to get a very very quick approval
and so now that seems dirty business it
is dirty but it's there's a kind of a
rational reason for it as the agency
said
we simply don't have enough
personnel
to quickly process these applications
so congress said
okay well we're going to get the
industry to give you the money to hire
the people to process it
but really what happens is the agency is
now being paid to do its job by the
industry and they become partners and
they're no longer
a regulatory agency they're really you
know they're they're
regulatory mission gets
subsumed by these commercial and
mercantile you know forces yeah business
big business
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you